welcome to 69 machine learning some of
you know that this closet or the
Stanford for a long time and this is
often the cost that I most look forward
to teaching each year because this is
where we've helped I think several
generations of Stanford students become
experts in machine learning golf built
many of their products and services and
startups that I'm sure many of you I
pray all of you are using today so what
I want to do today was spend some time
talking over logistics and then spend
some time you know giving you a
beginning of an intro talk a little bit
about machine learning so about 229 you
know all of you have been reading about
AI in the news about machine learning in
the news and you pray heard me others
say as a new electricity much as the
rise of electricity about 100 years ago
transformed every major industry I think
AI already we call it machine learning
but the rest of world seems to call it
AI machine learning and an AI and deep
learning will change the world
and I hope that 3 2 3 9 will give you
the tools you need so that you can be
many of these future titans of
industries that you can be one the gold
and don't you know hope the large tech
companies do the amazing things they do
or both your own startup or going to
some other industry go go transform
healthcare or go transport
transportation or go put a self-driving
car and do all of these things that
after this class I think you'll be able
to do you know the majority of students
applying the demand for AI skills the
demand for machine learning skills is so
vast I think you all know that and I
think it's because machine learning has
advanced so rapidly in the last few
years that there are so many
opportunities to apply learning
algorithms right both in industry as
well as in academia I think today we
have the English department professors
trying to apply learning algorithms to
understand history better we have
lawyers trying to apply machine learning
inter-process legal
humans and off-campus every company both
the tech companies as well as a lot of
other companies that you wouldn't
consider tech companies everything from
me faction companies healthcare
companies the just six companies are
also trying to apply machine learning so
I think that um if you look at it on a
factual basis the number of people doing
very valuable machine learning projects
today it's much greater than it was six
months ago and six months ago is much
greater than it was twelve months ago
and the amount of value the amounts of
exciting meaningful work being done in
machine learning is very strongly going
up and I think that given the rise of
you know the amount of data we have as
well as the new machine learning tools
that we have it would be a long time
before we run out of opportunities you
have before before society as a whole
has enough people where the machine
learning skill set so just as maybe I
don't know 20 years ago was a good time
to start working on this internet thing
a lot of people that started working on
the internet like 20 years ago and
fantastic careers I think today is a
wonderful time to jump to machine
learning and the number and the
opportunities for you to do unique
things that no one is no one else is
doing right you are paying for you to go
to logistics company and find an
exciting way to apply machine learning
will be very high because chances are
that logistics company has no one else
even working on this because you know
they probably can they may not be able
to hire a fantastic Stanford student as
a graduate cs2 29 right girls don't they
just on a lot of CSUN graduates around
um so what I want to do today is do a
quick intro talking about logistics and
then we'll spend the second half of the
day you know giving an overview and talk
a little bit more about machine learning
okay and oh and I apologize I think that
this room according to that sign there
seats what 300 something students I
think we have like not quite 800 people
and wrote in this class
so if there are people outside and all
of the classes are recorded broadcast on
SCPD they're usually the videos usually
made a very available same day so for
those who they can't get into the room
my apologies you know there are some
years where even I had trouble getting
into the room but I'm but hopefully you
can wash you you better wash all of
these things online shortly OSE yes yeah
I don't know it's a bit complicated yeah
thank you I think it's okay yeah okay
yeah yeah for the next few classes you
can squeeze in and use at the NCC so for
now might be too complicated so quick
and shows um
oh I'm sorry I should have introduced
myself my name is Andrew and I want to
introduce some of the rest of the
teaching team as well
is a class coordinator she has been
playing this role for many years now and
helps keep the trains run on time and
make sure that everything of course
happens when it's supposed to so she'll
be and then what throat
cause my Santa be the co-head TS
respectively a PhD students working with
me and so bringing a lot of own
technical experience technical
experience in machine learning as well
as practical know-how on how to make
these things work and with the large
class that we have we have a large ta
team maybe I won't introduce all of the
TAS here today but you meet many of them
throughout the school sir but the TAS
expertise span everything from
conversions and language processing
technology to robotics and so through
this quarter as you work on your class
projects I hope that you get a lot of
help and advice and mentoring from the
TAS all of which all of whom have deep
expertise not just in machine learning
but often in a specific vertical
application area of machine learning so
depend on what your projects we try to
match you to a TA they can give you
advice they're most relevant whatever
project you end up working on um so you
know go with this class I hope that
after the next ten weeks you will be an
expert in machine learning it turns out
that you know and I hope that after this
class you'll be able to go out and build
very meaningful machine learning
applications either in an academic
setting where hopefully you can apply it
to your problems in mechanical
engineering Electrical Engineering and
English and law and and education and
all of this wonderful work that happens
on campus as well as off the grass from
Stanford to Bill apply to whatever jobs
you find one of the things I find very
exciting about machine learning is that
it's no longer a sort of pure tech
company only kind of thing right I think
that many years ago
machine learning it was like a thing
that you know computer science
department would do and that the elite
AI companies like Google and Facebook
and Baidu and Microsoft with you but now
it is so pervasive that even companies
that are not traditional tech companies
see a huge need to apply these tools and
I find a lot of the most exciting work
these days and maybe some of you guys
know my histories I'm a little bit
is very I let the Google brain team
which help Google transform from what
was already a great company ten years
ago to today which is a great AI company
and then also let the AI group that
might do and you know let the company's
technology strategy to help I do also
transform from what was already a green
company many years ago to today arguably
China's greatest AI company so having
let the you know build the teams that
let the AI transformations of two large
tech companies III feel like that's a
great thing to do but even beyond tech I
think that um there's lot of exciting
work to do as well to help other
industries to help other sectors embrace
machine learning and use these tools
effectively but after this class I hope
that each one of you will be well
qualified to get a job at shiny tech
company and do machine learning there or
go into one of these other industries
and do very valuable machine learning
projects there um and in addition if any
of you are taking this class with the
primary goal of being able to do
research in machine learning you know so
actually some some of you I know are PhD
students I hope that this class will
also leave you well equipped to really
read and understand research papers as
well as you know be qualified to start
pushing forward the state-of-the-art so
let's see so today so just as machine
learning is evolving rapidly the whole
teaching team we've been constantly
updating CS 229 as well so it's actually
very interesting I feel like the pace of
progress in machine learning has
accelerated so it actually feels like
that the amount we changed the cost
year-over-year has been increasing over
time so so if your friends that took the
class last year you know things are a
little bit different this year because
we're constantly updating the class to
keep up with what feels like slow
accelerating progress in the whole field
of machine learning so so so so there
are some logistical changes for example
we've gone from what we used to hand out
paper copy
of handouts that where we're trying to
make this class digital-only but let me
talk a little bit about prerequisites as
well as in case your friends have taken
this class before some of the
differences for this year um so
prerequisites we are going to assume
that all of you have a knowledge of
basic computer skills and principles so
you know Big O notation Q stands binary
trees hopefully you understand what all
of those concepts are and assume that
all we have a basic familiarity with
probability right that hopefully you
know what's the random variable what's
the expected value of a random variable
what's the variance of a random variable
and if for some of you maybe especially
the SCPD students taking there's
enrollee if there's been you know some
number of years since you lost the
probability and statistics Falls we will
have review sessions on Fridays where
we'll go over some of this prerequisite
material as well hopefully you know
whether random variable is what the
expected value is but if you are a
little bit fuzzy on those concepts we'll
go over them again at a discussion
section on Friday also seeing the
familiar basic linear algebra so
hopefully that you know what the matrix
was a vector how to multiply two
matrices and multiplying majors in a
vector if you know what an eigenvector
then that's even better if you're not
quite sure what an eigenvector is look
over it uuugh but yeah we'll go over it
I guess um and then um a large part of
this class is having you practice these
ideas through the homeworks as well as I
mentioned later a open-ended project and
so one there we've actually until now we
used to use MATLAB in octave for their
premiere assignments but this year we're
trying to ship the permian Simon's to
Python and so I think for a long time
even today you know I sometimes use
octaves their prototype because the
syntax the octave is so nice and just
run very simple experiments very quickly
but I think the Machine there in the
world
you know really migrating I think from
MATLAB Python world to increasing using
MATLAB octave world to increasingly a
Python maybe and then eventually for
production Java or C++ kind of world and
so we're rewriting a lot of the
assignments that this causes quilter
I've been having driving that process so
that so that this course here you could
do more of the assignments maybe most
maybe all of the assignments in Python
numpy instead now an oath of the only
codes we all said you know we we
actually encourage you to form study
groups so you know up and I'm fascinated
by education a long time for a long time
studying education in pedagogy and how
instructors like us can help support you
to learn more efficiently and one of the
lessons I've learned from the
educational research literature is that
for highly technical classes like this
if you form study groups you will
probably have an easier time right so so
CS News and I would go for the highly
technical material there's a lot of math
so the programs are hard and they have a
group of friends to study with you
probably have an easier time because you
can ask each other questions and work
together help each other um where we ask
you to draw the line or what we ask you
to do relative to the standards on the
codes is we ask that you do the homework
problems by yourself right and and and
more specifically is okay to discuss the
homework problems or friends but if you
but after discussing homework problems
with friends we ask you to go back and
write up the solutions by yourself
without referring to notes that you know
you and your friends have developed
together okay the classes on the code is
written clearly on the class handouts
posted digitally on their website so if
you ever have any questions about what
there's a lot of collaboration and what
isn't allowed please refer to that
written document on the course website
where we distract us more clearly but
out of respect for the Stanford honor
code as well as the
your students kind of doing their own
work we asked you to basically do your
own work for the soca to discuss it but
after discussing home problems with
friends ultimately we asked you to write
up your problems by yourself so that the
homework submissions reflect your own
work right and I care about this because
turns out that having CS 239 you know CS
229 is one of those classes that
employers recognize I don't know if you
guys know but they're been um
companies that have put up job ads that
say stuff like so long as you got solace
you complete the CST three now and we
guarantee you get an interview right
I've seen stuff like that and so I think
you know in order to maintain that
sanctity of what it means to be a CSU to
nine computer I think and I all said all
of you so the really do work or stay
within the bounds of accepted of
acceptable collaboration relative the
honor codes let's see and I think that
um if you know what this is and I think
that one of the best parts of CS 339 it
turns out is excuse me
oh yeah sorry I'm gonna try looking for
the mouse cursor
all right serve all that might might
might displays on not smear erisa so
this is a little bit awkward um so one
of the best parts of the class is she
sorry about that
right no mind I won't do this you could
do that you could do yourself online
later yeah I started using I started
using Firefox recently in addition to
Chrome it was just a mix-up um one of
the best parts of the class is the class
project and so you know one of the girls
of the qualities to leave you well
qualified to do a meaningful machine
learning project and so one of the best
ways to make sure you have that skill
set is through this class and hopefully
with the help of some of the TAS we want
to support you to work on a small group
to complete a meaningful machine
learning project and so one thing I hope
you start doing you know later today is
to start brainstorming maybe of your
friends some of the some of the class
projects you might work on and the most
common class project that you know
people do in CSU's you know it's the
picker area pick an application that
excites you and to apply machine
learning to it and see if it can build a
good machine learning system for some
application in the area and so if you go
to the course website
you know cs2 2/9 does time for the edu
and look at previous year's projects you
you you see machine learning projects
applied to pretty much you know pretty
much every imaginable application Under
the Sun everything from no diagnosing
cancer to creating arts to lots of
projects apply to other areas of
engineering applying to application
areas in EE or my contouring or silver
engineering or earthquake immersion and
so on to applying it to understand
literature it's applying it to know and
and and and so if you look at the
previous year's projects many of which
are posted on the course website you can
use that as inspiration to see the types
of projects students complete completing
this class are able to do and also
encourage you to you can look at that
for inspiration to get a sense of what
you'll be able to do at the conclusion
of this class and also see if looking at
previous year's projects gives you
inspiration
for what you might do yourself so we
also know we invite you I guess to do
class projects in small groups and so
after class today also encourage you to
start making friends in the class both
for the purpose of forming study groups
as well for the purpose and maybe
finding a small group to do a class
project with we ask you to form project
groups of up to size three most project
groups end up being size two or three if
you insist on doing it by yourself
right without any partners that's
actually okay - you're welcome to do
that but but but I think often you know
having one or two others to work with
may give you an easier time and for
projects of exceptional scope if you
have a very large project it just cannot
be done by three people sometimes you
know let us know and we're open to work
with to some project groups of size four
but our expectation but we do whole
projects you know with a group of four
to a higher standard than project group
size one to three so so what that means
is that if your project team size is one
two or three persons the grading is one
criteria if your project group is bigger
than three persons we use a stricter
criteria when it comes to creating class
projects okay um oh and that reminds me
I know that the scene so for most of you
since is since this starts at 9:30 a.m.
on the first day of the quarter for many
of you this may be this / your very
first cause at Stanford for how many of
you does your very first cause at
Stanford Wow cool okay awesome
great welcome to Stanford oh and there's
someone next to you just raise their
hand actually raise your hand again so I
hope that you know maybe off the class
today if someone makes you raise their
hand
welcome them to Stanford and then say hi
and show yourself and good friends I'll
do it cool nice nice to see so many of
you yeah
all right so just a bit more logistics
so let's see in addition to the main
lectures that we'll have here on Mondays
and Wednesdays
since 39 also has discussion sections on
held on Fridays that are and everything
we do including the see all the all the
lectures and discussion sections are
recorded and broadcast through SCPD
through the online website and one of
and discussion section are taught
usually by the TAS on Fridays and
attendance at discussion sections is
optional and what I mean is that you you
know you punch up some promise there
won't be material on the midterm that
will sneak in from the section so it's
hundred-percent optional and you will be
able to do all the homework and
appropriate projects without attending
in this question section but what we'll
use the discussion section for for the
first three discussion sections so you
know this week next week week after that
we'll use the discussion sections to go
over prerequisite material and great to
Jeff so go over linear algebra or basic
crime statistics teach a little about
Python numpy in case you're less
familiar with those frameworks so do
that for the first few weeks and then
for the discussion sections that are
held later this quarter will usually use
them to go over a more advanced optional
material for example cs50 now involved
in learning algorithms you you hear
about in the class rely on convex
optimization algorithms but we want to
focus the class on the learning
algorithms and spend less time on convex
optimization so if you want to come and
hear about more advanced concepts in
convex optimization we'll defer that to
a discussion section and then there are
few other advanced topics hidden Markov
models time series that were planning to
defer to the Friday discussion sections
okay
so let's see
cool and oh and final bit of logistics
there'll be there are digital tools that
some of you have seen but for this class
will drive a lot of the discussion
through the online website Piazza how
many of you abuse Piazza Cavour
okay cool mostly Wow all of you that's
pretty amazing good so so online
discussion board for those of you that
haven't seen it before but definitely
encourage you to participate actively on
Piazza and also to answer all the
students questions I think that one of
the best ways to learn as was contribute
you know back to the course as a whole
is if you see someone else ask a
question on Piazza if you jump in and
have answer that that that often helps
you and helps your classmates so I
strongly encourage you to do that for
those of you that have a private
question you know sometimes we have
students reaching out to us too with a
personal matter or something that you
know it's not appropriate to share on
the public forum in which case you're
welcome to email us at the cross email
address as well and we also and the
class the email address the clock
teaching staffs email address on the
course website you can find it there in
contact us but for anything technical or
anything reasonable to share the class
which includes most technical questions
that most logistical questions write
questions like you know chief can you
confirm what date is it midterm or you
know what happens can you confirm
Wednesday handout for this going on and
so on for questions are not personal or
private in nature strongly encourage you
to post on Piazza rather than emailing
us because statistically you actually
get a faster answer posting this on post
posting on Piazza then then you know if
you wait for one of us to respond to you
and we'll be using great scope as well
for online grading if you don't know why
brace go up is don't worry about it well
we'll send you links and show you how to
use it data
oh and again relative to want one loss
which is a real thing to plan for unlike
previous
yes when we taught CS 339 so we're
constantly updating the syllabus right
the technical content to try to show you
the latest machine learning algorithms
and the to pick up little changes we're
making this year I guess one is a Python
instead of MATLAB and the other one is
instead of having a midterm exam you
know that's a timed midterm we're
planning to have a take hold midterm
this quarter
this day so I know some people just
breathing sharply when I said that I
don't know what that means
was that shock full happiness don't
worry midterms are fun you love it
all right oh so that's it for the that's
it for the logistical aspects let me
check with you and so let me check there
any questions
oh yeah go ahead oh yeah so that's such
thing oh let's see I think has offered
in spring and one of the presses
oh yes and I was teaching it so someone
else is teaching it in Spring Quarter I
actually did not know it was going to be
offered in winter so I think a big guy
teaching notes in
Neverending right teaching it in spring
and I don't think is often in winter
well this kind of sections be recorded
yes they will be oh and by the way if
you wonder why I'm recording that I'm
repeating the question I know it feels
weird I'm recording for the microphone
so that so that people watching those at
home can hear the question but both the
lectures and the discussion sections
will be will be recorded and put on the
website maybe the one thing we do
there's not recorded and broadcast at
the office hours right oh oh but I think
this year we have a 60 hour how many on
60 office hours per week right yeah so
so so hopefully I just again we're
constantly trying to improve the cause
in previous years one of the feedback we
got was that the officers are really
crowded so so we have 60 60 hours of
football 60 offers all slots per week
this that seems like long so hopefully
if you need to track down one of us
track down the teeth to get help
hopefully that'll make it easier for you
to do so good say okay well oh well
logistical things like when Homer said
you be covering lectures we have a yes
so we have four plans homeworks yeah and
if you go to the if you go to the course
website and click on the syllabus link
that has a calendar with when each
homework assignments called and when
Opie do so for homeworks and project
proposal due few weeks from now and then
final projects due at the end of the
quarter but all the other exact dates
are listed on the course website
oh sure
yes difference between this class into
39a let me think how does dead yes so
yeah I know I was debating earlier this
morning how to answer that is no doubt
that a few times so I think that what
has happened at Stanford is that the
volume of demand for machine learning
education is just right skyrocketing
because I think everyone sees everyone
wants to learn this stuff and so so
whooping so the computer science
department has been trying to grow the
number of machine learning offerings we
have we actually kept the enrollment at
CSC 39a at a relatively low number at a
hundred students so I actually don't
want to encourage too many of you to
sign up because I think we might be
hitting the enrollment cap already so so
please don't all sign up for CC 90
because we - 398 does not have the
capacity this quarter but since 229 a is
a much less mathematical and much more
quite relatively more apply version of
machine learning and so I guess I'm
teaching 69 ACS 230 NCSU now in this
quarter of the 3 CS 229 is the most
mathematical it has a little bit less
apply than 63 9 a which is more apply
machine learning and since 230 which is
deep learning
my advice to students is that 63 962 9s
is let me write this down
so since 229 a is taught in a flipped
classroom format which means that
students taking and will mainly watch
videos on the Coursera website and do a
lot of programming exercises and then
meet for weekly discussion sections but
it's a smaller class with captain Romans
I would advise you that if you feel
ready for cs50 9 + CS 2:30 to do those
but cs50 9 you know because of the math
this is a this is a very heavy workload
and pretty challenging class and so if
you're not sure we're ready for CCTV 969
a may be a good thing to take first and
then cs50 90s TV 9 a cover a broader
range of machine learning algorithms and
cs2 30 is more focused on deep learning
algorithms specifically right which is a
much narrower set of algorithms but it
is you know one of the hottest areas of
deep learning there is not that much
overlap in content between the three
classes so if you actually take all
three you learn relatively different
things from all of them in the positive
has students simultaneously take to 29
and 229 a and there is a little bit of
overlap you know they do kind of cover
related algorithms but from different
points of view so so some people
actually take multiple of these classes
at the same time but sooner nine is more
applied a bit more you know practical
know-how hands-on and so on and much
less mathematical and CS 230 is also
less mathematical more applied more
about kind of getting to work whereas
see Susan honey we do much more
mathematical derivations in c ester's
so why'd you say that what I would
generally prefer students not do that in
the interest of time but what what do
you want oh I see
sure go for it who's enrolled in 239 to
3000 not that many of you interesting oh
that's actually really interesting cool
yeah
thank you yeah I just didn't want to say
the presence of students using this as a
forum to run surveys so that was that
was that was an interesting question so
thank you cool all right
and by the way I think you know just one
thing about Stanford is on the AI world
machine they're in the world
yeah is bigger than machine learning
right machine is bigger than deep
learning um one of the great things
about being a Stanford student is you
can and I think should take multiple
classes right I think that you know
since we're now in has for many years
been the call of the machine learning
world at Stanford but even beyond CS 239
is worth your while to take multiple
classes including multiple perspectives
so so if you want to be really effective
you know after you drive don't stand
there you do want to be an exponent
machine learning you do want to be an
expert and deep learning and you
probably want to know probably in
statistics maybe you want to know bit of
confidence optimization maybe you want
to know bit more about the force when
learning know a little bit about
planning a little bit about lots of
things so so I actually encourage you to
take multiple classes like this if there
are no more questions let's go on to
talk a bit about machine learning so all
right so in the remainder of the sauce
what I'd like to do is give a quick
overview of you know the major areas of
machine learning and also
and and also give you absolute overview
of the things you learn in the next ten
weeks so you know what is machine
learning right it seems to be everywhere
these days and it's useful for so many
places and and I think that and you know
and and I feel like if either just to
share view my personal bias right you
you read the news about these people
making so much money building learning
algorithms I think that's great I hope I
hope all of you go make up all the money
but the thing I find even more exciting
is the meaningful work we could do right
I think that you know I think that every
time there's a major technological
disruption which there is now through
machine learning it gives us an
opportunity to remake large parts of the
world and if we behave ethically in a
principled way and use these super
powers of machine learning to do things
that you know helps people's lives right
maybe we could maybe you can improve the
health care system maybe you can improve
give every child a personalized tutor
maybe you can make a democracy run
better rather than make it run worse but
I think that the meaning I find in
machine learning is that there's so many
people that are so eager for us to go in
and help them with these tools that if
you become good at these tools it gives
you an opportunity to really remake some
peace some meaningful piece of the world
hopefully in a way that helps other
people and makes the world kind of makes
the world a better place is very cliche
in Silicon Valley but but I think you
know with these tools you actually have
the power to do that and they've got
make a ton of money that's great too but
I find a much greater meaning in the
work we could do but um
despite all the excitement of machine
learning what is machine learning so let
me give you a couple definitions of
machine learning author Samuel whose
claim to fame was building a checkers
playing program defined it as follows
fields I think is computable II learned
well being explicitly programmed and you
know interesting when when also samuel
many many decades ago wrote the checkers
playing program
the debates of the day was coming
computer ever do something that it
wasn't explicitly told to do and Arthur
Samuel wrote checkers playing program
but that through self play learned what
are the patterns of checkerboard that
are more likely to lead to win versus
more likely lead to a loss and learn to
be even better than Arthur Samuel the
author himself at playing checkers so
back then there was viewed as a
remarkable result there the computer
program huh you know that could write a
piece of software to do something that
the computer program that himself could
not do right because this program became
better and also Samuel at the toss of
played checkers and I think today we are
used to computers or machine learning
algorithms outperforming humans on so
many tasks but it turns out that when
you choose a narrow tasks like speech
recognition on a certain type of tasks
you can maybe surpass human level
performance if it was a narrow toss like
playing the game of goal then by
throwing really tons of computation
power at it and self play you can have a
computer you know become very good at
these narrow tasks but this is maybe one
of the first such examples in history of
computing and I think this is still one
of the most widely cited definitions
right gives computer disability learn
while being explicitly programs
um my friend Tom Mitchell in his
textbook defined this as well-posed
learning problem program said to learn
from experience ee respect to toss T on
some performance measure people on t as
measured by P improves experience you
know and III asked on this I asked Tom
if he wrote this definition just because
he wanted it to rhyme
he did not say yes but I I don't know um
but in this definition the experience II
for the case of playing checkers the
experience he would be the experience of
having the checklist the program play
tons of games against itself so
computers lots of patience sit there for
days playing games of checkers against
itself so that's the experience II the
toss T is the toss the playing checkers
and performance measure P maybe was the
chance of this program winning the next
game of checkers it plays against the
next opponent right so so we say that
this is a well-posed learning problem
doing anything checkers now within this
set of ideas of machine learning there
are many different tools we use in
machine learning and so in the next ten
weeks you learn about a variety of these
different tools and so the first of them
and the most widely used one is
supervised learning let's see I want to
switch to the whiteboard do you guys
know how do i erase the screen
so what I want to do today is really go
over some of the major categories of
machine learning tools and and so that
what you learn in the next by the end of
this quarter so the most widely used
machine learning - is today is
supervised learning actually then we
check how many of you know what
supervised learning is two-thirds half
of you maybe okay cool let me just
briefly define it um here's one example
let's say you have a database of housing
prices and so I'm gonna plot your data
set where on the horizontal axis I want
to plot the size of the house in square
feet you know and then the vertical axis
will plot the price of the house right
and maybe a dataset looks like that and
so horizontal axis I guess we call this
X and vertical axis we'll call that Y so
um the supervised learning problem is
given the data set like this to find the
relationship mapping from X to Y and so
for example let's see yeah let's say
let's say you have a let's say you are
fortunate enough to own a house in
Colorado and you're trying to sell it
and you want to know how to price the
house so maybe your house has a size you
know of that amount on the horizontal
axis this is five inches square feet
1,000 square feet 1,500 square feet so
your house is 1250 square feet right and
you want to know you know how do you
price this house
so given this dataset one thing you can
do is fit a straight line to it right
and then you could estimate so predict
the price to be whatever value you read
off on the vertical axis so in
supervised learning you are given a data
set with infos X and labels Y and your
goal is to learn a
from X to Y right now fitting a straight
line to the data is maybe the simplest
possible maybe the simplest possible
learning algorithm maybe that one of the
simplest on learning algorithms given
they said like there's there many
possible ways to learn the mapping to
learn the function mapping from the
input size to the estimated price and so
maybe you want to fit a quadratic
function instead maybe that actually
fits a date a little bit better and so
how do you choose among different models
will be either automatically or manually
vention will be will be something we'll
spend a lot of time talking about now to
give a little bit more to define a few
more things this pickle example is a
problem called a regression problem and
the term regression refers to that D
value Y you're trying to predict is
continuous right in contrast here is a
here's a different type of problem so
problem that some one friends were
working on and I'll simplify it was was
a healthcare problem where they were
looking at breast cancer breast tumors
and trying to decide if a tumor is
benign or malignant
right so tumor you know serve a lump in
ER in a woman's breast is it can be
malign or cancerous or benign meaning
you know roughly there's not that
harmful and so if on the horizontal axis
you plot the size of a tumor and on the
vertical axis you plot is it malignant
or not so malignant means harmful rate
and some tumors are harmful some are not
and so whether it's malignant or not
takes only two values one or zero and so
you may have a data set like that
right and given this can you learn a
mapping from X to Y so that if a new
patient walks into your office was in
the doctor's office and the tumor size
is you know say this can i learning
algorithm figure out from this day there
that it was probably well based on this
data set it looks like there's a there's
a high chance that that tumor is
malignant so so this is an example of a
classification problem and the term
classification refers to that Y here
takes on a discrete number of variables
so for a regression problem Y is a real
number I guess technically prices can be
rounded off to the nearest dollar
instead so prices aren't really real
numbers because you pretty not price of
how's that like pi times 1 million or
whatever but so but for all practical
purposes prices are continuous so we
call them housing price prediction to be
a regression problem whereas if you have
two values that possible help was zero
one call that classification problem if
you have K discrete outputs so if the
tumor can be malignant or if there are
five types of cancer where and so you
have one of five possible outputs then
there's also a classification problem
that the output is discrete now I want
to find a different way to visualize
this data set which is let me throw a
line on top and I'm just gonna you know
mat all this data on the horizontal axis
upward onto a line but I'm going to use
a symbol ol to denote I hope what I did
was clear so I took the two sets of
examples that positive and negative
examples positive example was this one
negative example zero and I took all of
these examples and kind of push them up
onto a straight line and I used two
symbols I use OHS to denote negative
examples and I use
processes in our positive examples okay
so this is just a different way of
visualizing the same data but drawing it
on a line and using you know two symbols
to denote the two discrete values around
one right so um it turns out that in
both of these examples the input X was
one-dimensional it was a single real
number for most of the machine learning
application to work with the input X
will be multi-dimensional and you won't
be given just one number and also
predict another number instead you often
be given multiple features or multiple
numbers to predict another number so for
example instead of just using two
messiahs to predict to estimate
malignancy open malignant versus benign
tumors you may instead have two features
where one is tumor size and the second
is age of the patient and be given a
data set maybe I'll sit and be given the
data set that looks like that well now
your task is given two input features so
X's tumor size and age you know like a
two dimensional vector and your toss is
given these two input features to
predict whether a given tumor is
malignant or benign so the new patient
walks in the doctor's office and that
the tumor size is here and the ages here
so that point there that hopefully you
conclude that you know this patients
tumors probably benign very
corresponding oh that's a negative
example and so one thing one thing you
learn next week is a learning algorithm
that can further straight line to the
data as follows
kind of like that to separate out the
positive negative example several out
the holes and the crosses and so next
week you learn about the logistic
regression algorithm which
and do that okay so one of the most
interesting things you learn about is
let's see so in this example I drew a
dataset with two input features when I
said I have friends that actually worked
on the breast cancer prediction problem
and in practice you usually have a lot
more than one or two features and
usually you have so many features you
can't plot on the board right and so for
an actual breast cancer prediction
problem my friends are working on this
well we're using many other features
such as don't worry about what these
need mean I guess clump thickness you
know uniformity of cell size uniformity
of cell shape right at Heejun how will
the cells sync together
don't worry about what these means but
if you're actually doing this in a
actual medical application there's a
good chance that you'll be using a lot
more features than just two and this
means that you actually can't plot this
data right it's too high dimensional you
can't plot things higher than three
dimensional maybe four dimensional
something right and so we have all the
features are you difficult to plot this
data I'll come back to this in a second
in learning theory and one of the things
you learn about so as we develop our
rhythms you learn how to build
regression algorithms or classification
algorithms that can deal with these
relatively larger number of features one
of the most fascinating results you
learn is that you also learn about an
algorithm called support vector machine
which uses not one or two or three or
ten or hundred or million input features
but uses an infinite number of input
features right and so so so just be
clear if in this example the state of a
patient will represents as one number
you know tumor size in this example you
get two features so the state of a
patient will be represented using two
numbers tumor size in the age if you use
this list of features maybe a patient
arrives enter with five or six numbers
but there's an algorithm called the
support vector machine that allows you
to use an infinite dimensional vector to
represent patients and how do you deal
with that and how can a computer even
store an infinite dimensional vector
right I mean you know computer memory
you can store one girl number two real
numbers but you can't store an infinite
number of real numbers in the computer
without running on the memory or
processor speed or whatever so so how do
you do that so we talked about support
vector machines and specifically the
technical method called kernels you
learn how to build during the algorithms
that work with so that it infinitely
long
lissa features infinitely long list of
features for which you can imagine that
if you have an infinitely long list of
numbers to represent a patient that
might give you a lot of information
about that patient and so that is one of
the relatively effective learning
algorithm problems um so that's
supervised learning and you know let me
just some play a video show you a fun
slightly older example of supervised
there in the previous hands what this
means but at the heart of supervised
learning is the idea that during
training you are given inputs X together
with the labels Y and you're given both
at the same time and the job of your
learning algorithm is to find a mapping
so that given a new X you can map it to
the most appropriate output Y so this is
a very old video made by a Dean
Pomerleau known for a long time as well
on using supervised learning for
autonomous driving this does not save
the art for Toms driving anymore but it
actually does remarkably well oh and as
you you hear a few technical terms like
back propagation you learn all those
techniques in this cause and by the end
of class you've really built a learning
algorithm much more effective than what
you see here but let's let's see this
application
could you turn up the volume maybe have
that are you guys getting volleyball
yeah I see
alright I'll narrate this Oh so I'll be
using artificial neural network to drive
this vehicle that was built at carnegie
mellon university many years ago and
what happens is during training it
watches the human drive the vehicle and
I think ten times a second it digitizes
the image in front of the vehicle and so
that's a picture taken by a front-facing
camera and what it does is in order to
collect labelled data the car while the
human is driving it records both the
image such as the scene here as well as
the steering direction that was chosen
by human so at the bottom here is the
image turned into grayscale and lower
res and on top let me pose this for a
second this is the driver direction the
phone's kind of blurry but this Texas
driver direction so this is the Y label
the label Y that the human driver chose
and so the position of this white bar of
this white blob shows how the human is
choosing to steer the car so in this in
this image the white blob is a little
bit to the left of center so the humans
you know steering just a little bit to
the left this second line here is the
output of the neural network and
initially the neural network doesn't
know how to drive and so it's just
outputting this white schmear everywhere
you say you know I don't know do I Drive
left right center
I don't know so stop putting this gray
blur everywhere and as the algorithm
learns using the back propagation
learning algorithm or gradient descent
which you learn about you actually learn
about gradient descent this Wednesday
you see that the neural networks output
becomes less and less of this white
shmear this white blur but starts become
sharper and starts to mimic more
accurately the human selected driving
direction
so this um there's an example of
supervised learning because the human
driver demonstrates inputs X and outputs
y maybe if you see this in front of the
car steer like that so that's x and y
and after the learning algorithm has
learned you can then well he pushes a
button takes a hand off the steering you
know and then it's using this network to
drive itself right digitizing the image
in front of the note taking this image
and passing it through the learning
algorithm through the trained neural
network letting the neural network
select the steering direction and then
using a little motor to turn the wheel
this is a slightly more advanced version
which has trained two separate models
one for I think a two-lane road one for
a four-lane roads so that's the so the
second and third lines this is for a
two-lane road this is a four-lane road
and the arbitrator is another algorithm
that tries to decide whether the two
lane of the four-lane road model is the
more appropriate one for a particular
given situation and so as Alvin
destroying excuse me a one named world
or two lane road so it says driving from
a one lane road here toward an
intersection
the the algorithm realizes is just
switch over from I think I forget what I
think the one lane or network today to
the two lane your network and one or
season
okay oh all right fine we just see the
final dramatic moment as searching for a
one-day road to tuning all right and I
think you know so this is just using
supervised learning to take as input
what's in front of your car to decide on
steering direction this is not so the
odds for how self-driving cars are built
today but you know you could do some
things in some limited context and I
think within several weeks you actually
be able to build something that is more
sophisticated than this um so after
supervised learning we will in this
class to spend a bit of time talking
about machine learning strategy you know
I think on the class nails we annotate
this as a learning theory but what that
means is um I want to give you the tools
to gaulden apply learning algorithms
effectively and I think I've been
fortunate to have you know to know a lot
of I think that um I've been fortunate
to have you know over the years
constantly visited lots of great tech
companies more than ones that I've dead
that I've been probably associated with
right but often just a home friend zone
I visit various tech companies of the
Sun whose products I'm sure installed on
your cell phone but I often visit tech
companies and you know talk to the
Machine there any themes and see what
they're doing and see if I can help them
out and what I see is that there's a
huge difference in the effectiveness of
how two different teams could apply the
exact same learning algorithm and I
think that what I've seen savvy is that
sometimes there will be a team even in
some of the best tech companies right
the the elite AI companies in multiple
of them where you go talk to a team and
they'll tell you about something they've
been working on for six months
and then you can quickly take a look at
the data and and hear that did not the
album isn't quite working and sometimes
you could look like what they're doing
and go yeah you know I could have told
you six months ago the disapproval is
never gonna work right and what I find
is that the most skill machine learning
practitioners are very strategic by
which I mean that your skill at deciding
when you work on a machine learning
project know you have a lot of decisions
to make right
do you collect more data do you try a
different learning algorithm do you ran
faster GPUs to train your learning oven
for longer or if you collect more data
what type of data is you collect or for
all of these architecture choices using
neural networks what vector machine
which is regression which one do you
pick
but there are a lot of decisions you
need to make when building these
learning algorithms so one thing that's
quite unique to the way we teach is we
want to help you become more systematic
in driving machine learning as a
sabbatical
engineering discipline so that when one
day your work on machine learning
project you can efficiently figure out
what to do next
and sometimes make an analogy to how to
a software engineering
you know I many years ago I had a friend
that would debug code by compiling it
and then this friend will look all these
syntax errors right that you know see
pluses compiler outputs and they thought
that the best way to eliminate the
errors is the delete all the lines of
code with syntax errors and that was
their first serious thing so that did
not go well right took me a while to
persuade them to start doing that Oh
but-but-but-but so it turns out that
when you run a learning algorithm you
know it almost never works the first
time is just life and the way you go
about debugging the learning algorithm
will have a huge impact on your
efficiency on how quickly you can build
effective learning systems and I think
until now too much of the of this
process of making your learning Urban's
work well has been a black magic kind of
process where you know as
it's the decades so when you run
something and don't know why it's not
working I hate what I do and says oh
yeah I'll do that and then and then
because he's so experienced it works but
I think um what we're trying to do with
the discipline of machine learning is to
evolve it from a black magic tribal
knowledge experience based thing to a
systemic engineering process right and
so later this quarter as we talk about
machine learning strategy or talk about
learning theory you try to suspect to
give you tools on how to go about
strategizing so can be very efficient in
how you how you yourself how you can
lead a team to build an effective
learning system because I don't want you
to be one of those people that you know
waste six months on some direction that
maybe could have relatively quickly
figured out what's not promising well
maybe one loss analogy if you if you use
the optimizing code right making code
run faster not tell me if you learn that
less experience software engineers will
just dive in and optimize the code to
try to make it run faster right let's
take the C++ and code in the 70 or
something but more experienced people
will run the profiler to try to figure
out what part of your code is actually
the whole night and then just focus on
changing on that so one things hope to
do this quarter is convey to you some of
these more systemic engineering
principles
oh and actually this is a actually I've
been down I've been writing this up
actually so how many of you have heard a
machine there on in your name oh just a
few of you interesting so actually - so
if any of you interested just in my
spare time I've been writing a book to
try to codify systemic engineering
principles for machine learning and so
if you are and so if you want a you know
free draft copy of the book sign up for
a mailing list here I tend to just write
stuff and put it on the internet for you
so if you want a free drop copy of the
book
you know go to this website enter your
email address and the website was saying
Jerry copy of the book they'll talk a
little bit about these interview
principles as well okay all right so so
first object machine learning second
subject learning theory and the third
major subject we'll talk about is deep
learning and so you know the lot of
tools in machine learning and many of
them are worth learning about and I use
many different tools the machine
learning you know for many different
applications there's one subset of
machine learning that's really hot right
now because it's just advancing very
rapidly which is deep learning and so
we'll spend a bit of time talking about
deep learning so they can understand the
basics of how the training your network
as well but I think that um whereas 2:29
covers a much broader set of out rules
which are all useful see su-30
more narrowly covers just deep learning
so other than deep learning slash after
after deep learning such new neural
networks the other the the fall of both
of the five major topics we'll cover
will be an unsupervised learning so one
is unsupervised learning
so you saw me draw a picture like this
just now right and this would be a
classification problem like the tumor
malignant benign problems this is a
classification problem and that was a
supervised learning problem because you
have to learn the function mapping from
X to Y unsupervised learning would be if
I give you a data set like this with no
labels so you just give in inputs X and
no why and you're asked to find me
something interesting in this data
figure out you know interesting
structure in this data and so in this
data set it looks like there are two
clusters and then unsupervised learning
algorithm which you learn about called
k-means clustering will discover this
this structure in the data other
examples and so I was learning you know
if you actually Google News is a very
interesting website sometimes I use it
to look up right latest news there's an
only example but Google News every day
crawls or reads many many thousands or
tens of thousands of news articles on
the Internet and groups them together
right for example there's a set of
articles on DPP all well still and it
has taken a lot of the articles written
by different reporters and grouped them
together so you can you know figure out
that what BP Macondo all well write that
this is a CNN article about the whole
world still there's a guardian article
about all well spill this example of a
clustering algorithm where is taking
these different new sources and figuring
out that these are all stories kind of
about the same thing and other examples
of clustering just getting data and
figuring out what groups belong together
all the work on genetic data this is a
visualization of the genetic microwave
radiator we're giving it like this you
can group individuals into different
types of individuals at different
characteristics or clustering algorithms
grouping this type of data together is
used to organize computing clusters you
know figure out what machines workloads
are more related to each other and
organize communities probably so to take
a social network like LinkedIn or
Facebook or other social networks and
figure out which are the groups of
friends on which are the cohesive
communities within a social network or
market segmentation actually many
companies I've worked with look at the
customer database and cluster the users
together so you can say that looks like
where four types of users you know looks
like that there are the young
professionals looking to develop
themselves they're the you know soccer
moms and soccer dads that the discount
in this case who can then market to the
different market segments separately and
and actually many years ago my friend
Andrew Moore was using this type of data
for astronomical data analysis group
together galaxies question Oh is almost
worse than the clustering knows not so
as well as well as learning brought me
is the concept of using unlabeled data
so just X and finding interesting things
about it right so for example actually
here's shoot this won't work with all
audio will do this later in the clock in
the class I guess maybe I'll save and do
this later cocktail party problem is
another unsupervised learning problem
reading the audio for this to explain
this though everything how to explain
this
you know cocktail party problems I'll
try to do the demo when we can get all
your work on this laptop there's a
problem where if you have a noisy room
and you stick multiple microphones in
the room every call overlapping voices
so there no labels readers and multiple
microphones my array of microphones in a
room with lots of people talking how can
you have the algorithm separate out the
people's voices so that's an
unsupervised learning problem because
there are no labels you just stick
microphones in the room and have a
record different people's voices over
that
voices multiple Utah at the same time
and then haven't tried to separate out
people's voices and one of the pro next
Assizes you do later is if we have you
know five people talking so each
microphone there cause five people's
overlapping voices right because you
know each microphone here's five people
at the same time how can you have an
algorithm separate out these voices so
you can't clean recordings of just one
voice at a time so that's called a
cocktail party problem and the algorithm
you used to do this is called ICA
independent components analysis and
that's something you implement in one of
the latest homework exercises and there
are other examples of us who has
learning as well the Internet has tons
of unlabeled text later you just sucked
down data from the internet there no
labels necessarily but can you learn
interesting things about language figure
out what figure out I don't know one of
the best cited results recently was
learning analogies like you know man is
the woman as king of the Queen right or
what Tokyo mister Japan as Washington
DC's the United States right to learn
and energies like that some say you can
learn analogies like that from unlabeled
data just from text on the internet so
there's also unsupervised learning okay
um so after on sooo eyes learning oh and
I'm surprised earning so you know
machine learning is very useful today
turns out that most of the recent wave
of economic value created by machine
learning is through supervised learning
but there are important use cases for
unsupervised learning as well so I use
them in my work occasionally and there's
also beating edge for a lot of exciting
research and then the final topic find
out the five topics we cover so talk
about supervised learning machine
learning strategy deep learning
unsupervised learning and then the fifth
one is reinforcement learning
is this which is um let's say I give you
the keys to Stanford on this helicopter
this hyung copters actually sitting in
my office I'm trying to figure out how
to get rid of it and I'll see the ready
program to make it fly right so how do
you do that so this is a video of a
helicopter flying the audio is just a
lot of helicopter noise so that's not
important but uh well zoom out the video
you can see it responds in the sky right
but so you can use learning out of yeah
that's kind of cool
I was the cameraman that day oh but so
you can use there any algorithms to get
you know robots to do pretty interesting
things like this and it turns out that a
good way to do this is through
reinforcement learning
so what's reinforcement learning um it
turns out that no one knows what's the
optimal way to fly a helicopter right if
you find helicopter you have to control
sticks that you're moving but no one
knows what's the octal way to move the
control sticks so that way you can get a
helicopter fly itself is let the
helicopter do whatever you think of it
us training a dog right you can't teach
a dog the optimal way to behave but
actually how many have a pet dog a pet
cat before
it's fascinating
okay so I had a pet dog when I was a kid
and my family made it my job to train
the dog so how do you train at all you
let the dog do whatever it once and then
whenever the Hays well there you go oh
good dog and when it misbehaves you go
bad dog
and then over time the dog learns to do
more of the good don't things and fear
of the bad dog things and so
reinforcement learning is a bit like
that
right I don't know what's the awful way
to fly a helicopter so you let the
helicopter do whatever it wants and then
whenever it flies well you know doesn't
mean everybody whines or flies
accurately without getting around too
much you go
oh good helicopter and when it crashes
to go bad helicopter and it's the job of
the reinforcement learning algorithms to
figure out how to control it over time
so as to get more of a good helicopter
things and fear that bad
couple of things um and I think um well
just one more video yeah all right and
so again given a robot like this I
actually don't know how the programmer
actually you know robot like this as a
Lolich joints right so how do you get a
robot like this to climb more obstacles
so well this is actually a robot dog so
you can actually say good dog dog but by
giving those signals called a reward
signal you can have a learning algorithm
figure out by itself how's the optimize
the reward therefore climb over these
types of obstacles and I think recently
the most famous application is a very
for student learning happened for game
playing playing Atari games or playing a
game of gold can alphago I think that uh
IIIi I think that uh game play has made
for some remarkable stunts a remarkable
PR but I'm also equally excited or maybe
even more excited about the integrals
their reinforcement or anything is
making it's a robotics applications so I
think I think yeah reinforcement has
been proven to be fantastic for playing
games is also getting making real
traction in optimizing robots and
optimizing logistic system things like
that so you learn about all these things
last thing for today I hope that you
will start to tell me people in the
class to make friends phone project
partners and study groups and if you
have any questions you know dog on the
Piazza ask you questions let's help
others answer the questions so let's
break for today and I look forward to
seeing you on Wednesday
you